I can't wait hopefully this is this is
working here so all right we are
probably live chances are people won't
see this unless they're actually on
YouTube I'm here I'm Jonathan France and
right now it's on Twitch only book right
the people they're gonna see this
they're only gonna see it because
they're on YouTube no one's gonna
actually see this on Twitch at least for
like a few minutes until our thing pops
up on the the light chest thing saying
that we're streaming and then some other
people notice we're streaming and jump
aboard I am joined right next to me by
the one and only Danny Machuca
who got this thing all kicked off and uh
you know he gets the cool job today
sitting there watching everything is
that the actual thing where I see the
chat yeah you know it'll start right
there it's just no one's doing it it
looks different is that the same screen
residual yeah there's two ways to view
this chat
what's you know just watching it like a
normal okay sure all right so today we
will be doing another episode of play
the people so go ahead and throw some
5-minute challenges at me I think that's
probably a good one
so it says Mike plays people which is a
good way to get people in maybe I want
people to think Mike comers here but
he's not sure Mike will be here at one
o'clock which is an hour from now so he
could jump into the stream at some point
all right Paul bo-buddies here this is
good
you just play some random game while we
wait I wonder what our blitz rating is
on this thing but yeah
we'll do it just a five-minute game here
just a little warmup see how how rusty I
am today so here we go before so just
playing some random person not a viewer
at some point I expect to see a lot of
challenges up here and the thing how
does it look
does it look all right can people see
the board and hopefully when people are
here they tell me if they hear me yeah
they can well maybe nobody's watching
like I like the other view better
because it tells me how many people are
watching so believe I can play 95 here
cuz if you take my con I can throw them
in there should to be six which looks
stronger and this is the structure
perfectly yeah this is structure Fabi
was going for in the World Championship
so I expect it to be pretty good yeah in
general I guess I just want to castle I
want to play moves like before see five
in some order
yeah you go to like show okay so I'm
gonna play this I kind of want to play
Queen to d2 Knight a5 before c5 look my
rooks in somewhere wherever the rooks go
bring him in etc
okay so do challenge me I don't see any
challenges yet five vote today looking
for 500 Rea did prepare ibly and you can
play me so yeah I guess black is
deciding she wants to take or push or
not do anything just like not to do
anything um so he's gonna be on my beep
on at some moment hopefully that's an
okay square for a rook again Queen d2 95
that's my idea
if ever this pawn moves I get to see six
square and white should be a little bit
better here so where is his 100% sure
where his bishops going I'm just going
on an adventure
my idea attacking this pond probably
defend it I'll play before
and now the pot then I can also if he
ever has to he can go back and support
the c5 probably would bring my rook in
place e5 but I should do something over
here to get some active counter play
what it could be we will see so yeah
wait brakes turn on the Queen side but
then black checkmate it's white that's
what's going on here hello
ah codex a - I guess I can see the chat
now he says hello hello very exciting to
have you I'm trying to decide where my
rooks belong I feel like it's c1 and d1
so I'm actually gonna move this rook I'm
not exactly sure what black is doing
over on the Kings side so I'm not too
worried about it maybe I ought to be but
maybe I'm I might already be ready to
play c5 if I want to where I could
patiently bring my rock in use all my
stuff
I'm gonna wait one move because mmm miss
King each one of you soon
yeah but not sure if I want to use the
normal usual move oh just go oh all
right this is what you play king each
one uh coward what for scary yeah window
I'm scared
yeah you're a big Sicilian player now oh
yeah um Danny it's a funny story
his Grandmaster coach said stop playing
the London and stop playing boring stop
playing the Petroff you play the
Sicilian though so this is for you Danny
is why I'm playing this um could do
funny stuff like take a fork I don't
think this is any good but I could do it
she says something
so many options all right to choose
alright let's keep going
sucess some some question what he's
gonna do
I suppose I will take with a night she
recaptures me that we did in this phone
and yeah again I haven't really seen
what blacks big idea is over here just
taken with the night quickly without
much thought um maybe ro takes was
better here we are
seem to have decent control over this
position it's just solidify
okay so at some point I will need to
make some progress here
maybe I didn't want to take with my
night it was a joke
are you taking miss then
all right Danny's here so we've been
playing as one okay so I know I know
you're getting worried over there so
yeah
take your phone no you're gonna take my
phone I think your problem
dang it took my pun there was nothing
nothing that I could have done it was
just zero things that could have
possibly been different there so you
turned more fun
how can you do you know chess work see
just they just take your pawns and then
you get man yeah so took my pond was
upsetting
I'm upset no one else to tell you I'm
upset
yeah yeah so I made a mess out of this
how to fix it no idea yeah
just zero ideas here so nothing can be
done
we take second throw in the check first
if I want to I can take back because
this is projected
hard to say
hello sir
that was a kv con ah that's a long one I
think I've seen Jonathan and his chicken
arm friend in a spider-man movie I'm not
sure there's your chicken armed friend I
don't know do you know what that means
no okay
1700 GM yeah yeah sounds about right
this is an account that quite a lot of
people will be playing on I'm gonna be
doing some streams on Tuesdays about
this time that's gonna be sort of a
regular thing and there will be others
let's see what is the hole it'll be on
Wednesday so tomorrow it'll be Ryan
Chester you ought to help me with the
times because they don't know the the
set time um I think it's three yeah
three o'clock
yep so look forward to Ryan Chester who
is the chess club manager who will be
doing it tomorrow whoever the GM and res
is so next Thursday don't be Dinesh
Mauro she'll be here doing you know
you'll be doing it at 3:00 yeah and Mike
comer rounds it out on Fridays so four
days a week we're doing this and his
thing is that like 2:30 in the afternoon
yeah okay so we're starting to get a set
schedule as this year goes on don't
really know what I'm doing in this game
that's not gonna stop me from doing
probably what do you in exchange but
he's gonna like make it after night f70
over--overseas
stop that cheated jitter take it
yeah I think if all else fails just
accuse your progress of cheating even
though there's obviously no reason to
suspect this day the eighth but I've did
not get checking me don't go check my
did yeah what's my King doing on that
square okay so is this actually better
me yeah it's quite bad right yeah ah
that's funny I have one trick but he
made a queen so like he wins but there's
my one little one trick yeah can't
believe he stopped me plagued him yeah
yeah that's what most of this dream is
gonna be about it's important to get off
to a nice slow start so there's nowhere
to go but up
go make your dad I got is fun
we have to make a series of random moves
fast yes today
today that was another thing I was
hoping in the future we can't do it this
week because we weren't equity
breadboard but I have like the the
German razz stream during like roaches
leak or something run it by the team but
I think we can go on YouTube and start
saying things like we should do this
alright did I win hey easy winner yes
it's at least a chance yes we drew yes
we're so good alright thank you for the
game Jota 73 hmm way and good job me not
losing okay big fan of your semi slow
video series why do you think they
stopped playing it at the highest level
I think it's just fashionable semi-soft
is obviously still good yeah I mean
there's nothing wrong with it alright so
we got our first challenge from a viewer
here though net self one st. Louis took
the pickle mmm good to see you chess
whiz same melissa's both Wesley so and
Fabi on her team I know it's such an
exciting year for our pro chess League I
think we're the early favorites which is
which is always good who's the demon
residence is far far today in tomorrow
it becomes Ganesh bullsh
the fire will not be live streaming
today he's doing classes and he's
teaching at a high school um yeah so we
got a little Colie with b3 here that
move surprises me a little I'm just
gonna rip this general I'm just gonna
drag you my stuff out here and castle
all right basically I'm just gonna copy
him for a little bit until things get
serious
which might be right now
maybe my move was actually bad because
maybe no I should have played Queen to
c7 maybe not giving him time for things
like f4 but we are fine yeah and he's
here to encourage me emotionally so I
assume it's fine
hey it's got warmer you want to come in
but I have to play some move here so no
trouble I have to play a move which is
always hard I'm not good at just playing
just move you know any good moves here
Kyle trying to get on the stream so you
have to be on here this time we're using
Danny's thing because you can see the
mouse so let me know so we were using
the TriCaster before you guys couldn't
see the mouse when I moved it around and
I guess now I can see it but we're just
using Danny's computer not the TriCaster
because I like being able to see the
mouse when people are playing chess
okay my stupid idea is to play off six
and then get check me out someone says
you they have a free hand on the white
side there
what is your feed a rating it's
1970-something
here's the rotation of upcoming GM's
you want lessons I can give the GM's a
group lesson just whiz big time talker
maybe he's you know maybe he's on Team
Magnus though he's telling the truth
monster hunter unite good to see you is
the protest League being streamed on
Twitch not by us but yeah lots of
lots of people will stream you know wash
and raise calm or something yeah they so
you can always watch over it's doing it
see a cop um yeah I'm gonna get
checkmated what's the bullring
freedom
yeah so
I was gonna really try hard this stream
I told myself I'm gonna sleep in which
for me means getting up at like 6
o'clock or something I'm not gonna go to
the gym I'm gonna just sleep in take it
easy and then by the time my stream
comes around to have lots of energy that
was my plan but it didn't pan out that
way my body just woke up at 4 a.m. which
is the usual time I wake up when I go to
the gym so uh you know I got to get my
excuses in order because I can already
tell I'm gonna lose a lot of games but
uh you know I'm tired that's an excuse
lots of kids that's this is my go-to um
don't you have all your excuses in order
it's easy you can just blame all your
losses on that so it's important we just
get that all out there now protests
League is the twitch channel so you can
watch the thing on yeah them they have
their own twitch so it's like a big
internet thing I'm sure all the twitch
people are just like twitch people
excuse game is tight at least if not
chess yeah that's important I sit around
late at night not thinking of how well
I'm gonna play chess I'm like what kind
of excuses do I have and then yeah that
gets me through the day
not enough coffee that's another one
enough coffee going on we maneuvered
this guy deaf six
I'm honestly not sure why he put his
queen there but I guess is his goal is
to checkmate me my goal is to win this
pawn I also have a goal of trading have
a goal of not losing this pawn but no
promises
alright I just don't want to get tricked
mated so I'm gonna try to trade the
Queens these knight just coming in
that's a bit scary so if I get trade the
Queens I'll be able to play move like h6
if the knight ever bugs me too much it
also might be heading to some other
really nice square like e5 not losing
pawns is a good goal yeah I mean you
know trying to try to think of the easy
stuff Dani said yesterday he wanted to
use I guess the protest League we tried
to change his mind though he might lose
this Caleb is that a caleb did I know
yeah we're gonna be banging streaming
this year though I don't know if
protests link is on the docket but
there's gonna be a lot of streaming this
year so we're still getting in the hang
of it so really any suggestions you guys
have are always welcome because we had a
lot to learn Dani Machuca
all right welcome back hiyee 45 hf6
interesting name hey tonight um your
name not playing particularly well or
with any particular plan but we're
making legal moves and then we'll beat
some random position and we'll take it
from now you also have difficulty it
always shows that people are following
and whatever have difficult time seeing
it someone likes my videos thank you
very much I doubt you know me and you
live in the Netherlands alright there's
actually quite a lot of Caleb's in the
area there's two of them that are both
2,100 they live in the area so I thought
maybe you were one that I might have
known how did you talk to Dani if you
don't live here
let's move the spoons yeah you like if
it's good to see you
neo medic znation chess what's up
h6 g5 attack yeah yeah um this is what
I'm mostly looking at see that clock app
see I don't have to play well I just
brought my stuff out and didn't do
anything so I can at least flag you're
not gonna like win on the board if you
don't really have a plan or anything if
you just chill out you can win but uh
thank you to vet elf one all right maybe
I should try to play a good game well I
should only can do is try that's the
only final that's rated and you are in
the chat so I'm give it a go yeah five
Oh today people is what we're going for
all right the new zone and I was looking
at this line with somebody I think this
weekend so when he gives us a go this is
all new to me takes what the bishop that
seems slightly unusual normally they
play Knight a6 and then they recapture
with the night I'm leaving this line you
go here the other line you play g3
Bishop g2 but this seems like a
situation where I might want to play III
I put my bishop somewhere else
u2 or d3
B&C - is unambitious yeah certainly not
bad though certainly a reasonable
attempt see nation didn't play catalan
no longer my favorite chess lecturer oh
no now used to be my go-to that's when I
was good though I used to play the
Catalan and win every game but then I
gave it up and now I just lose so is
everyone in st. Louis minimum 1500 Ehlo
not even close
that's yeah I don't know what percentage
that is but that's probably way over
like 60 70 % percentile 80% oh that's
really good so buddy you might go here
one day I'm just gonna go here and I'm
gonna castle
and hopefully he doesn't play Bishop e7
d5 and crush me and put all his rooks
here was clean here he's gonna do all
this and he's gonna crush me that's
right no no quick I might want to fish
up Perry all right oh yes crushing oh
yeah it just got better the second Perry
walked in look at that see or he had
this deep sacrifice in mind peace you
drop a piece I think so what are you
looking at Swiss Miss okay yeah I played
him that you I played my one right so I
could I could show the stream but you
know this is gonna play the people I did
I took down my carp later yeah yeah yeah
my comer now we played the same guy we
just played because we were playing
house game directing the tournaments so
due to 1799 he was for a while yeah he
had a bad patch or something rough
patches a psychological barrier 1 or 2
points they need yeah but he also sort
of I think enjoys he feels comfortable
well I mean okay you know ever there's
like an under 18 prize pervades I guess
so
oh there you are - oh yes you gained a
point a quick point I didn't gain a
standard for ya
I gained a quick point yes wait now if
you click on this right place right yeah
yeah I know I gained a serious 1/2 point
there oh wow I got the floating points a
half of a reading point I'm also kind of
taking this name there I'm also waiting
for the chat to come back up they're
saying like funny things no chat right
now ah come on I need to talk to other
people it's been Boyd played but
different one you know but what do you
think this is gonna win upon for sure
also this would also be strong
everything's strong for me so 1400 is
like here percent here's a 1400 ok so
this is we didn't have to actually
insert other people probably asking
other questions where you going so yeah
so maybe ferry will get to play on this
stream well 1400 is 81st percentile so
yeah and yeah and in this state is 777th
percentile that's my oh he's in Ohio
though okay crushing yeah yeah we're
just taking on stuff you took my queen
these are talking your queen what do you
do about this a bit hmm somehow good
she's covering this square it's like not
much so apparently it's like really easy
to cheat so hopefully people aren't
listening to the strai think the belly's
a little different when we do he's the
best when he's a fatty sir I'm not it's
good to know that young is because I am
NOT I'm not the best when I'm up stuff
all right this is put our other night
there yeah z nation yeah I was ok I
think this is the first screen I've seen
at 2160 ok before he's a big man in my
church
yeah I wish I could say I was the best
when I'm up a rook or a piece all right
so I don't make that claim
you line that up hopefully how many more
material here yes thank you for the game
8:45 what are they talking about we're
talking about religion mostly yeah uh
Honda Accord our good buddy go for a
plane someone's playing the ice cream
all right they want to see the Magnus
opening it's a coward hammer is the
standard yes I don't get the GM since
many people use the account one ones a
GM all's the GM that's what we say check
yeah hopefully that slightly interrupts
them and then hopefully not all right
step back it's all right through your
something longer piece we'll never know
doesn't mean much these days
yeah just whizzes a GM too so yeah you
know he's just a robot you guys what
that robot he's just a robot yeah okay
never be a grandma job the integer that
is okay y'all right works is probably
some local stores we've all been to all
right don't know what's going on here
but I'm up upon this things week also
means this is he's gonna sack here and
check me see if I can find all the ways
I'm gonna lose he's also gonna take this
and then take this that's another way
I'm gonna lose
and then this in the US and then Queen
here and then I think I got checkmated
my Honda nothing there's nothing I can
do absolutely nothing feels a bit slow
but come on
this is all predicated on the fact that
if you can take I'm hoping I can take
with this thing
my night disappears this thing isn't
protective keep an eye on that just
wisss now if really you guys are great
no more trolling now we love the and I
do like trolling take the subtlety
sometimes some people are too subtle for
my liking I can't tell if they're
trolling or not okay so I'm hoping if
this bishop moves I'm gonna give serious
thought to taking this and then throwing
a knight up in here attacking this thing
here we go serious thought now that I
considered it deeply at the highest
level I think I'm gonna move my queen
away and move my bishop out amazing yeah
yeah after being rejected the idea of
giving away a mission for a night I'm
really missionary videos I missed them
too
that was those were the good old days
back when you could edit stuff you
didn't have to be live all the time yeah
and then you could make lots of mistakes
and people wouldn't knoe have you
thought about doing a live video I have
actually I think that would be that
would be an interesting thing cuz we all
have sort of we get sort of an hour a
90-minute block once a week that's sort
of a thing with different evil you know
it doesn't have to be play the people
all the time it could sometimes be some
some opening video I'd have to come up
with a cool name though and I'm not good
at that sort of stuff everyone seems to
love your Dutch opening video series
part 3 I know it needs to happen
I almost mostly Bishop d2 there didn't
watch it completely yeah I got the
reason I was I was expecting to have
exactly enough time to sneak in one more
Dutch video before I they tell me it
doesn't
well yeah I mean that's obviously a
consideration bananas not as much
anymore I'm just gonna look use all my
stuff find a way to do it it sits right
here root takes up three if there's a
rucksack that's what it does that's
possible Honda do I give online chess
lesson it's not at the moment
thinking about it maybe I need my own
channel maybe I need a lot of stuff why
reading is just why reading yeah that's
I don't know why I'm not really a deep
question but yeah I'm like 1,900 if
you're asking once we're eating
I took heel he took back meant what
rating yeah what up Jonas oh my there's
no left back here goodness there's no
lift all right should i pinpoint this
thing at some point
I'm gonna find him oh yeah oh yes he's
lost yeah during these I'm spending most
my time looking at the chat so I don't
have really time to look at the board or
the time do you pay Fabia Wesley to play
for you Mike comer is the manager he
handles all of those decisions
what happened 95 let's protect how many
times what's going on how am I getting
tricked here Honda don't trick me I hope
I'm not getting swindled but I don't see
it so I'm gonna grab your stuff
I'm gonna take your stuff it says here
I'm +4 it says yes thank you for the
game under a cord that's very good
opening was a bit strange but yes answer
Perry's question yes c5 is not very
common here most people take and then
most people here they take on d5 if you
do play this line and white can throw in
this check at some point and get a stuff
that was supposed to be good for white
maybe black equalizes that's the point
but it's it's supposed to not be the
best line we got an LM but he's hoping
for a 300 maybe we marry for the lower
ones we can live Perry come in here and
somebody to help steal because the chess
capital only after the center opened up
it sure did another French Oh is the
life chess master ok I was joking might
be actually the case Perry which one
which line all right okay well like
chess masters 2200 or 2300 there's this
game asking it rapid I don't do it now
you hope for c5 cuz you go here you win
defense is just wins from Aladdin just
wins alright but black is lost here
already this is just a well known trap
the problem is it's hard to cover both
of these squares so I'm threatening to
go here if you prevent that by say
moving your unit to b6 I can happen here
at issues
good for white oh it's not about reading
so when this exchange I'd you have to be
really careful if there's a way that I'm
gonna lose to a 1395 it's I'm gonna be
up this exchange but I haven't developed
my stuff and then he's gonna end up
taking all my stuff and then something
Bad's gonna happen because he's gonna
take care of with something and this
Queens gonna check me and then yeah you
know I've been here before this is how
the bad things start they go there so I
guess I'm just gonna shut that down cuz
I've lost that way too many times I want
to bring up my stuff is that bad move I
was thinking just Bishop d3 and Knight
f3 let him live on King F - I think
that's - I think that's an eight seven
yeah up until that point about the
second but yeah he's really really
strong giving out OLM isn't giving out
anymore it used to be about super super
good guy in certain number of just very
okay
oh it's be good at variants do it again
it okay so what horrible thing is
happening to me water
oh that's unfortunate we can't become
Bell lamps okay my queen is being
attacked yes oh my queen
oh my gosh well why is it really good
yeah I know king can go to eat too and
be perfectly safe
that's what problems put it back you
mean mistake okay lek I apologize there
when I just back back the p1 thank you
okay then just uncheck on you too and
hope there's no follow-up roll I'm
streaming alone from now on
[Laughter]
someone's requesting a modern Benoni not
possible yeah the modern Benoni is no
baloney did it that was never made
though right no that was me that was it
Superman
hopefully he doesn't see that rule
nobody tell him know what thirteen
crossed out means
is it I never play f3 that's what looks
like Oh Oh f3 huh
screen is slanted I never played f3 so
you're being accused of having what was
wrong clean c1 um I thought after Queen
c1 Bishop before I guess I have to go to
e2 but I was just I don't know maybe
nothing but you didn't you didn't do it
my name is detective I'm really more
worried about this this guy I'm gonna
take this though hope he just took back
wow not actually surprised me removed it
- all right
that surprised me so he's gonna get that
night back but I should just be up
material I thought he was gonna I was
really a little bit more worried about
this Queen to b4 at some idea at some
point but now if you just expect one
night I can play Bishop d3 wrecking
castle inside okay that's a play Queen
h4 me and you know him right now clean
it for g3 and they takes Queen Castle
yeah that's what I did okay now I'm up
some amount of material I'll play Bishop
d3
why no long castle I guess there must be
a delay because you're a little bit
behind Jonas oh yeah I agree
phew is grassed yeah that could have
been a lot worse
but uh I do appreciate that pornography
is not listening to the stream that's
what that means that's a cool name
we're still mildly frustrating yeah not
anymore because well yeah but yeah I
assume they're just slightly behind
which is also good for me because I
don't really want people suggesting
those to me too but so if you guys are a
little bit behind then I can't cheat
which is also good it's not my intention
I'm threatening to take
surrounded move so I'm not sure if he
has some actual active flame here at
some point I'm gonna get going over here
probably bring this rug in not worried
about him taking my bishop and trading
so hopefully at some point he takes me I
guess this bishop would be really good
if they train a pieces or the bishop
ended up here I don't know how he's
gonna do that so which one can we read
it yeah yeah finally knowledgeable and
trained chef scholars right behind you
know yeah yeah no no also why does their
account have a GM title Thank You sirs
we who are cheaters the main reasons but
also it's because the GM feeling does
streams here every Thursday so it was
Markovian last Thursday it'll be Dinesh
Borel streaming is Thursday
number three chat is always GM level
yeah good to see you smoke craft haven't
seen you yet today I know you've been
around a couple times so we're getting
to know a couple people here yeah I
expect nothing but the highest quality
just analysis those are the cha-ching
yeah yeah alright
Wow Moses poses good to see you Chapas
Eric
yeah what is this little he's watching
no this means he's playing a game okay
yeah it's playing some game okay so
let's we can leave this here so people
that don't want to watch our game can
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's see what's going on over here was
Erick up to oh3 oh but he's blacking
this but not a three okay yeah I'm
watching my game are you yeah I'm not
paying attention to the scheme trade
I love trading eric is streaming himself
yeah that's what we thought how many
viewers does he have compared to us
probably hopefully more hopefully Attis
is he giving like New York blitz shield
whoa maybe we should join yeah we should
play Challenger let's watch Challenger
yeah yeah but yes not he's in the mobile
tournament yeah no no no I let him check
me oh the embarrassment he could have
put his Bishop on the ideal square
all right we're just gonna thank this
guy so we're not gonna because I am from
a better position yes
hopefully he opens this file and allows
this checkmate now yeah it looks like he
plays like tournaments there's a crank
right yeah that's a cool idea as well
that's another thing I speak good idea
consideration too yeah he's using stream
laughs but his stream lapses
yes all right thank you for the game
another for you okay what's going on in
the chat you guys can make your own
arena tournament oh they are new to this
we can tell how could you tell Perry's
kicking me out of my ass I'm going to
change the title is that right Perry
please senior circuit well you have to
play he had to play he had to play
old-fashioned openings to 75 means we
need one more chair 75 very good places
people to great that yeah how strong is
Perry that's in the comics can you beat
a 1,700 ran a grated game quickness
isn't my forte
we'll see what happens play the old
India ah this guy's good old they need
an offense we've been great this is uh
what is this opening some sort of
Sicilian I mean knight or hybrid oh now
it's a Bennigan's
I just try to play your best moves
that's a good idea yeah try to do not
the name of it is but no such event
again they go this is your baby gamer
playing here somehow I was like a knight
or there's like a sort of my door in see
me okay she Jonathan yeah exactly my
door fast old schooled indeed okay
Fisher era stuff someone claims get
close gonna check I've been missing out
I need to spend a lot more time talking
to the chat Sicilian it's hard not
because it's difficult dearie to
remember but because it's impossible to
get the variation names right school
indeed yeah the shaping it actually is
Louisville school I guess you can say
cuz far off made it pretty popular and
he's not too bad hold on over here we
have all the sex on e6 well calculated
here probably her ship take c6 would
shock you right bishops well I would
shock me
would sharply but you know whenever you
see you Mayo mayonnaise yourself
considering e5 tonight on c5 then you're
defending a e6 like a thousand times but
he's getting ready to play d5 I'm not
sure thinking about us or not see I was
thinking about 95
you're looking at all the Sicilian
variations there's a lot to choose from
have you forgot which one you're gonna
play yeah no I'm sort of playing
everything I mean I'm playing the dragon
and I'm playing this ship and again nish
think it's not really uh yeah all right
so dragon expert Danny but you guys here
for all your dragon questions take on c3
and that's the end of it hopefully they
get to my stuff McQueen sky was
disheartened after a little championship
in addition to the new twelve twelfth
moves Bobby tried in that profession of
composition there's I've saved ores my
book covers as well just way too much
yeah new profession took off to the pros
yeah yeah well yeah yeah I think he will
take that what the queenie takes your
depo
it seems like isn't it delay quite far
behind today actually so that's what I
was saying I think you find this
computer yeah that was larger delay yeah
I still think it's thirty seconds but
it's like it's a bit longer than a try
guesser whatever reason you have to be
fairly serious to study at eye level
yeah I mean like a world championship
level yeah yeah
and even then it didn't seem like all
that great for Pincus
despite however much time he spent on it
well I stuck to it he made drums he got
a good result in the first round is it
the first time he played especially
coffee was like losing him from where
well in first friend was the Sicilian
yeah
no well that was like they did the roast
of li mo for a while oh yeah
let me dev second half it worked out for
Magnus lemo in general though the pawn
structure you get after 95 and then they
take on d5 with either a knight or a
bishop it always has been
quite nice for white and I've always cuz
the plan is so simple played c4 c5 and
it's always good for weight so I like
playing that way in the most you saw
mine I North game that's how I just I
try to get that pawn structure and play
from there just some crazy stuff try to
check me guard holding strong yeah yeah
we're never gonna redo Magnus is the
goat the greatest of all time he's right
up there he's very good yeah probably
oh he is
although I think the next generation
will have someone better than Magnus
just because of better training yes
easier to get better and better
yeah stand on the shoulder and penance
for it
like I like it's probably called for to
play like Kiev or GA for defensive Oh
going to trying to get me wrong with the
club they say unless he thinks
got fast hands over here slow hand slow
hand like Eric Clapton slowly yeah
that's gonna be an issue
time to give me I mean I don't protect
this stuff sir oh so you can move your
room tonight afraid no they're playing
they're playing that's why they offered
job very playing if people don't realize
well it did it was that a challenge that
you accepted or such a draw good what's
what they call it GM a draw yeah it's
patron here we go 300 casual okay yeah
okay good oh well we only play rated now
yeah well your rating only goes up if
it's rated OD for you're serious you're
mad yeah yeah yeah
not joking around anymore against the
unicorns kill dragons right that's
master time controls unicorns kill
dragon this is at the clean room yeah
that's the claim I'm scared all right do
you what do you what do you play is
black now you have to play the eye
what's Jess I love go impressive given
how much I'm not trying I've only lost
once on a stream was very upsetting yeah
bar distracted you're right he came in
and yeah yeah yeah cool Grandmaster yeah
it was Gary Mars yeah I blame bar yeah
percent I thought he did anything wrong
he was just his mere presence is kind of
terrifying Oh unicorns supposed to kill
dragons yeah how does that work
I'm all on dragons team so if I get time
for this move I should feel happy wonder
if he's gonna chase me down and then
this is I think this actually is the
line where I can play like h4 here in
this crazy life is the nation I humans
hate losing something twice as much as
they enjoy acquiring it psychological
same for guys there's something for that
so I think this actually is a line they
play like they can hunt me down now if
they want some although eyes thing kind
of transpose to the main line which
would have already had the moves like a
five in the night come to see five and
actually like playing this Petrosian set
up as white we just do this early d5
because most people read a book and it
says you do this and black equal
oscillation yeah that was 95 and
everything's fine I don't think that's
quite the case I feel like white does
have a slight advantage and
my overall plan after I've you know not
gonna check me and stuff is to drive
this guy with at some point I probably
end up making these moves you know what
I think about to set up old school yeah
this is Petrosian playin like
petrosian's not so bad though okay I'm
sorry I'm like usually plays moves like
Bishop d7 think we deviate which makes
it really hard for me to get going
sometimes oh no no this isn't line isn't
it this is a line that I don't know no I
need to look this up no yeah yeah this
is a line blunders clean end story no no
this is the one you want easy job zero
combination no no this is London I don't
know it's already know Wow scary this is
lying yeah yeah yeah this is idea no no
this is an idea I don't think it's a
good idea seriously dangerous what's
dangerous about it maybe it's clean so
he's gonna take care yeah it just kind
of goes here this things come in this
things being taken executive
no no easily avoided this is like a
think Apsara found it calculated all
this right no no I don't know so it's
busted
no I need to figure this out I mean it's
wrong again it's like people who don't
know the theory but it doesn't mean I
see double
like what's theoretically probably
another lie neither oh my gosh okay here
yeah but that's all right
oh no no I have a better move also I'm
trying to avoid saying things on the
stream has ever seen this line before
looks scary yeah it does it is very it's
it's although I don't believe it it's I
don't think it theoretically works but
it might be scary in practice no this is
well now he has a real time real scary
thing oh okay so I'm gonna move this
thing do the optimal stop to the optimal
square obviously not gonna give you all
some pads R squared squared is that the
skirt yeah
or anything particular just be please um
I feel like I've weathered the storm
relatively well though so far I don't
think it was a lie I think no no this is
it's a really deep maybe thought it was
one looks like super real lost
this is hanging right give me oh there's
that too greedy that looks too greedy
because no gate and then pretend attack
here's a pretend attack on your key that
you can refute it like I'm scared I know
you're crazy you're crazy person but I
only said I had five no we have six and
then I like being around
I'm not a rated grab bones I just this
guys figured what I needed this position
I mean I guess he has to play broken
take yeah I mean obviously then he
pretends losing it makes it hard for me
to castle and he's got a thing yeah
working up to I'm just taking all
sponsor hey sing what is greedy there's
a very gritty guy yeah yeah I mean this
can happen at some point
you might argue that I should just get
on with it
kick it away it's gonna go here though
we have to take in this files gonna
brace your inner greed
yeah that's playing like so missus ah
look at that he's trying to make this
move even better so
he's gonna lose I know there's the next
yeah I've seen it
he's putting a spaceship here
no no that's my king sir sir good sir
oh how do I defend this thing easily
easily yeah it doesn't quite lose well
we'll only take on f3 and there yeah I'm
gonna block with microwave energy losing
bigger oh and then not care that I'm
losing color one time and it's just for
the record I'm gonna flag people I'm not
gonna be nice and get a job thank you
for the game unicorn yeah it'd be crazy
in here but only because you yeah there
was no time cuz you took as a fence like
the excitement yeah I am brick top
Jonathan is it better in the long run er
to learn the open Sicilian as white or
close Sicilian open obviously I want to
know what's best so I can set myself off
in the right direction
yeah I say be a man open it up
a professional in it like if you're if
you actually want to be a grandma you
know you're a real professional visual
challenge that's right well yeah cuz I'm
a theoretically but
so here we are and then you play this
you put this thing here I London master
yeah bring this in then you bring this
thing in hope for the best
the England gambit that's what they're
requesting so I assume this is not a
real that is ready for you efore c5
he did it though I thought this was not
a threat just as I was saying this is
not a threat he did it and he wins okay
good game good game that was fun what
was it if you take it was but Queen
takes Queen takes he's thinking this guy
well if you just take you a new pawn I'm
thinking he takes a thing yeah lay down
a piece yeah
all right good game huh that was fun we
all had fun and I sat there and I said
that's not a threat and then he did it
it was a threat how devastating no chaos
that's the only way I was Bishop d2
question all right we can't allow that
oh boy winning already know if you want
to know three things you just have to
play the bank other than anxiousness
impossible for me to win signed yeah I'd
be the funniest if I did yes a d4 c4 to
play huh you got all the stuff to London
I know just avoid all of that it's safer
gonna be a lot safer a little triangle
slowly try it out play them they don't
know any theory and then stand facing
the Benko against the Mengele trying to
thought you guys were gonna show me the
refutation of the Bangkok oh no that's a
free horse Department see specialist of
breaking it and he was just here during
some junior tournament and he's just
like every junior would played against
him and he'd be like what you're down
upon and then he would just easily win
yeah he happened to be the highest-rated
junior by a mile
but when I was there but didn't tap what
does the computer say about it like Lila
hasn't said you're down upon I mean
alpha hasn't tried it right Suze you're
down upon
oh that's aw I saw alpha played that
Dutch
yes they got refuted you should have
resigned when he played the bank oh yeah
it just wins against me doesn't really
in real life give me that all you think
is under attack
you could you could play rook takes
Bishop tonight to play here he takes me
write it this you did it I think I think
I think and there's no back rank ease
there's absolutely no back Rangi Baggies
oh good thank you strong
that's so fair if they're gonna be
strong if I good moves
so maybe I should keep the Queen's on
because yeah this is what's happening
but then how are you gonna keep your
people I mean you just just give it up -
yeah yeah crush it make me it can't be
anything so some discord then I can't do
it yeah he can just play this way um
rook takes nothing rook takes just send
a resigner
yeah pretty much
all right maybe but we'll play game by
flying or took me down took me down new
by my kryptonite I think that's what LM
me and this means he's like you know
spying on me he knows all my kryptonite
well played game oh Kramnik student all
right
one three one game this guy's are
brothers yeah come on
let me add kramnik student I like we're
sinking was diesel how much better I was
doing with e4 we're sticking with d4
because I'm playing against premix
student and what did people say they
want the Catalan camp it people want the
cattle or the cattle because I'm playing
those topics both have been requested
how's this work just some closed
Seaforth I'm relying on you mostly all
right is he playing a five-way before I
play oh yeah I'm just dead busted
absolutely no hope we'll see you that
time I better your dad can we say that
I'm better yeah yeah yeah isolated pawns
on the board yes he's dead exciting
wanna be on the stream Tony Chen we're
not don't thank him tell me Chen so you
have people's chant your name you
usually do whatever they want right
thank you for the fish I mean I actually
had it I haven't had lunch yet
yeah Tony Janice class the coordinator
he's been curing salmon yeah really good
it's not really good have you got
something else no no I have mine in the
fridge I've in it oh yeah yeah it's
really good did you bring extra cuz I
ate a lot yesterday we brought some in
for you but yeah right he's gonna put
some Rick here I'm gonna play clue b3
end of analysis I challenged five minute
because I'm sensible yeah yeah this is
too fast I mean I'm I'm also talking and
I'm thinking I have to play the
Christmas tree opening what's the fake
Kramden should have played the semi Josh
I don't know what the Christmas tree
opening is now you know you played every
Christmas
hey-ya if you have an isolated queen
pawn you lose
according to see nation yeah maybe
that's true I can take that still right
give me a kiss it's not that easy
I took it took his yeah also were you
threatening to take on the e4 and then
Bishop c4 oh no cuz he said he would
take with the Queen and II also at
Bishop d6 this time of year take down
the tree yeah I think when I go home
today I'm not gonna have a Christmas
tree in my house it's gonna be
depressing today's the day my wife takes
it out of the house not that that's what
they were talking about all right
Oh 99 people watching how exciting thank
you for has really dead but up no how
much are you still doing good good all
right just go back to the square I don't
know why I like it it's my square
no comment yeah yeah yeah a good thing
the chats
no it's not up here what's on YouTube
people will never see I think it was a
good idea too scary of that sexually
assume the other stream has probably had
something that needs to be removed
okay so there's so much you can bear
right I didn't see anything but he's
plotting something though I could feel
it I could feel the plotting
and I'm not really thinking so he's the
voice this is like Oh Danny Huachuca
yeah he's the behind the scene this guy
technical superstar as I believe is this
official title another personal sandy
I'd like to like your videos thank you
why did you why did you stop
yeah why did I stop um I had a had a kid
I had another cat and Jim took over a
little bit of a break and then he took
the spot so it's this fun yeah videos
are a big hit yeah yeah good to see you
Tommy bet good to see you John this is a
popular TV program wonderful is that how
you sound to people I don't know I'm too
used to your sound what's going on here
I'm absolutely no idea was going oh
you're playing that's new winning he is
an isolated pawn so weird is that simple
I know but I'm not gonna do anything
about it yeah I know for the record I
learned a lot from videos yeah cool I'm
glad you guys liked him Congrats on the
baby
yeah she's like one and a half now so
thank you very much neighbor it's weird
to her your voice not in two times speed
you can wait for YouTube and then I
assume you can you can crank it up
there's quite a lot of people that watch
all of our videos on to times people
yeah give me that
you can take whichever bishop you want
um probably not do this right yes heels
taught me thank Boren thank you I have
this funny move though
ah he stopped it because there was a
check and it wasn't even good for me but
it was you know funny so it was under
serious consideration
what is he plotting can you tell me
what's going on here cuz there's like a
pin so something Bad's gonna happen if
you could just point out the threats to
me like that Louis sure majority okay
well is he threatening anything yet it's
nothing yeah he's gonna take this one
worked maybe didn't work I don't know I
stopped him in case he was no no that
was this deep deep plotting no take it
take it I don't have to take it yeah why
can't I play Brooke h1 yeah you're
strong I'm not gonna take it cuz he said
that's so I was threatened to take it I
would've immediately blundered in my
rope
you know Creek student putting up a big
fight give me good yes
all right thank you joined yes I somehow
took him down
oh because he the great ks1 yes three
seconds I'll probably he meant to play
brookie six or something so thank you
though Greg I was dose cool I look
forward to mouse slipped yep
oh the Andy yeah and he missed okay miss
they said it was a game yep all right
good game criminy um just tone it down
it's been too hard we got about 20
minutes we're gonna play the Magma's
opening against a lower rated player how
does it work I don't know six and six I
have a lot of really mister flipper no
miss flippers the real deal okay that's
the guys name not at the opening it was
probably kramnik made the account when
he was a student
oh I suspect otherwise but he does seem
to be quite a strong player killer Mouse
PGG kf-x clam killed a plan oh my
challenge disappeared well just free
challenge them exchange French and then
some sort of emoji yeah I remembered why
I don't play the French against 1300
cause I play the exchange but deal with
it we're gonna still checkmate them
we're gonna play aggressive I do it
different than you do yeah somewhere the
settings and it's like just called what
kind of reading at this levels I'd
recommend for more tactics and playing
what best chess book is mastering chess
strategy by you on Hillston
when I was like this is series right you
talk about serious got me just
understand people but I'm just saying
yes as part of his series yeah um yeah
he's got like an opening and game and an
endgame but the strategy one that's
where it's at you want to know the best
book I read that when I was like 1300
and then I read the whole book and
instantly became 1800
it's interesting I never saw that book
till I came out here one book that has
me the most I think it was the art of
attack that was that's all my favorite
mm-hm I kept on
well trading the dark square bishop
helps him a little bit but I want a pun
and I shouldn't be safe
all right castle this way he has ideas
like my mp5 at some point
doesn't seem to work just yet but uh you
should somehow save this night castle
we'll take it from there was the name of
the book mastering chess strategy by
Johann helstem not by Neil McDonald
maybe he has a strategy book I don't
know what it does feel like there's one
no McDonald book I ever glanced at and
there was some sort of like ready he
wrote a book yeah right which I was
interested mastery in chess tactics
hey protected all right thank you
flippers so we got 20 more minutes so we
can get a couple more games in here we
will crank it back up crank it back up
rated this looks like the highest back
to you for curly Carlos percent of my
time should I spend on tactics training
from chest tempo D percent ninety
percent yeah it feels a bit high but let
me know how much all but I don't know
how much time you have things alright
we're playing a scotch how do I play
this I am expecting Danny to tell me so
I take this and I lose right here that's
a move yeah I don't know we're making
this up I'm just saying I don't get this
gosh
okay but yeah I know the Scotch expert
I'm playing it in your honor no Knight
takes c6 what was wrong Bishop takes and
then just you do cleanup for your
scenario spending four to five hours a
day okay that's very serious so I'll
take this now right job I would probably
do that too yeah I have a job at a chess
club yes exactly it's surprising how
little chess tiny that you have in your
chest Joe yeah
it's like you're I mean you're usually
teaching just I just had one glorious I
can help you when I was waiting at home
we were awaiting the birth of my first
child so nothing to really do and I
could spend 12 hours a day just got
serious a chest for like a short amount
of time and that's where plateaued after
that some point you have kids have you
got to pay the bills and you just just
goes down
yeah it just simples good I do like the
light chess tactics trainer a lot
because it's they take it right from
real games so I feel like that's
actually quite a useful feature I say go
chess the bowl just like right not
giving it a chance it's pretty new and
what I love it I assume it's really good
just haven't used it
I don't know if it's any better than the
other science book I just like no I want
to play my favorite chess club staff
who's your favorite cyber found the
sound setting good we're yeah we're it
depends on who you ask
oh no everything I saw this move but I
didn't realize oh we're busy talking how
bad this wasn't yeah whatever um but I
didn't realize okay let's get me work
who's your favorite staff
we'll get them you can play whoever you
want whoever all right he's deciding how
to crush me here
yeah
No okay you you helped us day out when
he came to the club all right who is it
saber yes there's also Eric now chess
opposed awesome you owe me paid new
jersey and t-shirts all right cacao
untestable they just got uh well they
have Jacob a guards book calculation and
yeah it's actually pretty cool if they
if they add Arthur you see pops books
then I'm I'm just gonna delete all my
other accounts
guessable I love Arthur stuff but it's
just so hard at times
come on please be trapped it was all the
cunning trick the whole time I totally
calculated all this correctly and your
night strapped and I win I'm a genius
currently Carlos you should know it
visit you guys three years in a row for
the Sinquefield Cup sweet yeah we get
quite a lot of people here for the sing
field mm-hmm so can I move my queen and
that bishops still super protected
doesn't feel right
but what you gonna do yeah okay maybe
book you recommended me it's for 1,800
to 2,300 players yeah the only took me
to 1800 what
oh you're duh yeah okay ah that was a
good move well then get chess what was
it called chess tactics from scratch
please don't I said we just you read it
too critics didn't read it yeah that's
good I just yeah I've never saw I don't
know I found it I mean I think I see was
just done
oh no no no I've spotted something
devious for my opponent know one of my
first books was by Eric Schiller
that wasn't that was a mistake no I
didn't know which I just didn't know I
was supposed to avoid that book I went
to Barnes and Noble it was just a big
guy that's not what I was worried about
I thought he could actually take with a
night cuz if I take there's gonna be
some sort of checking and then um this I
thought I would take here we're better
or for worse maybe well maybe after you
take and
yeah maybe he had rook d5 at some point
there in that variation no no everything
track yeah yeah what can you have no
wait wait a minute
oh yeah does that work what do you have
to take the rook first and then I know
it doesn't work as a don't watch
let's turn that's the arrows Jimmy you
know so Bishop takes f7 rook takes f7
and then Queen takes e4 no because then
he has to take takes on f - that's yeah
good luck you got it don't hear if you
just I guess he just trades it takes me
h5 excellent and that's your age all
right getting crushed again in down time
22 how did a Queenie to work Oh cuz it
was the start of a new traditions
alright let's we got so much counterplay
we're gonna crush them go us come on you
just effort he's gonna check me here to
defend us today yeah yeah
Oh curly Carlos giving me a hard time I
mean really what's he gonna do look good
i won oh yeah how could this backfire
okay let's just dig um and then
hopefully we get back and stop that guy
or we're in a lot of trouble
super exciting stuff here so he takes on
me to refute one or just you know here
today don't blink here he's just gonna
trade the rope chain or could he still
no pushed upon me
no he couldn't cuz then he had work
takes you sir
yeah that real q1 routes you to when we
trade off good thing to go here
very sad okay one and one one that I
didn't stuff too hard are Louis is too
strong for me you're not losing I'm not
losing my place about that yeah but it
was all the time just not on stream
Wow you never know you never know stroke
might be treating ya beat me I'm just
using solution is their protest leak
coverage that's yeah everyone wants to
protest like coverage currently Carlos
crushed me I their purchasing yeah
there's probably some stuff there maybe
I should have paused and calculated at
some moment but I didn't didn't you
played a great game
so the jumping the GG guys oh that was
yeah he's there oh okay game yeah yeah
great game Carlos why this guy's
requesting you play him what's his name
Duke we do so great
yeah don't see it not seeing the
challenge I don't see the challenge is
your school options oh yeah that's
really that's really you know that's
there's no we're gonna have to tone it
down I don't see a whole lot up hmm
Iraida challenges yeah um so I spend
time for about two more games will do
this one do one mark
that guy wants to know if Queen e2
worked then Queen e2 - yeah she still
owes a piece I know yeah I thought it
was I have to take a deeper look
Caroline again that's your new thing huh
yeah I'm doing this because earlier
today I know about the H completely on
accident mouse left I met to play
Sicilian by play car know about the a
jacuzzi yeah I know I don't know how
this opening works so we're in big
trouble here all I know is like I get
checkmated I develop my stuff to normal
enough places and then I get checkmate
it Jeffrey plays it yeah but I don't
need my nose in Castle King side and get
checkmate in Queen side diverse reasons
just get check my did
maybe you'll trick my name yeah I have
to play the mainline Karl codex cuz I
don't know anything else and I don't
know this is they're just you know I've
seen chess games in my life
yeah they go here and you castle and
think of like this then can you pings
over here him do you pretend check meet
him yeah yeah yeah I have just enough
counter play and it all works out to a
draw but that's you enter so I'm gonna
go this way cuz do it getting check me
you're always yeah it is fine but like I
can't I can't like it can be done but I
can't you gotta know your limitations
and I just got crushed by Carlos
why'd I go there D presents D prisons
there you go 1:22 no it's the typical
plan here I guess I'm supposed to be
playing flexi 5 or something really good
it's crazy
why that's the plan though right is it
I'm just trying to figure out the plan
sometimes you play openes you don't know
and you just like what's the plan oh
maybe it's this break and guess that
break this is c5 seems more realistic to
me or I'm supposed to not do anything
because I'm a fortress who knows what
I'm supposed to do alright we've crossed
over a hundred people probably for a
while now looks like that person is
talking to us yeah no we answered this
in the industry I think he did try he
like yeah yeah yeah and then he found a
chatter something he was just asking
about closest to the inter hope I say
open that's my official answer today I
think if you're serious you because they
don't make me better at yeah at
everything and just improves your
understanding and the Sicilians a
beautiful open Inka so it should be
played the proper way what do you guys
learn different lines in an opening use
chess base for all of my studies hmm so
you just plug it in on chess base you
see what good people have been doing
you'd play some lines see what's up you
also watch a lot of chests like we're
here obviously whenever the Cinco cups
playing all the good people are playing
so we just learned stuff because there's
good people around it's easy to learn
stuff when there's good people
surrounding you just paste that too and
I didn't see I come in lost my focus
no oh man this is really bad
this is really bad not really having a
fun time today I have to be honest I am
not having a fun time
books open explore yeah um if you have
access to chess base if you don't
there's a lot of free databases you can
use my chest just has one no yeah I
assume they're rosin rosin like doesn't
use just paste anymore
did you just use like yeah they're easy
yeah I don't it's crazy if it's good
well we're my queen gong and there's
some glitch fealty mister some 1400 I
get back to work that's why I knew to do
two openings I knew though this guy was
just gonna cross me which openings are
you particularly interesting learning
right now um usually I just learned
whatever people are playing around here
so the Queen c2 named Zoe I've actually
spent some time this weekend working on
what's happening here does that piece
yes I'm back in it yes I never doubted
myself um yeah it's cuz somebody
somebody played Queen c2 names Oh in a
tournament the Swiss Miss what just
happened and I said interesting I'll
give it a look they did so that's kind
of how I pick what I'm doing
what openings I'm learning I am sort of
interested in having at some point some
sort of like stream what repertoire were
it's mostly met where if I play this I'm
probably playing most often slightly
lower rated players to me so I should
have some repertoire for like winning
games instead of my repertoire for just
drawing it again but yeah so far right
now I'm just playing whatever on the
stream
oh yeah at some point I'll do that then
I can just have my stream repertoire and
my actual turn my repertoire and keep
them separate
oh and friend girl had a Queen c2
t-shirt school didn't see two news oh
it's uh it's good it's good
kind of poking around at each other here
yeah I mean don't get you don't get
checkmated just this time okay so now I
should get this pond which hopefully
will make it easier I guess he goes here
yeah so I guess I can take that you can
go here and then hopefully
then go here and here and it's about to
get really complicated
yeah maybe
so I guess I shouldn't up about this
yeah light chest analyze explore to get
something the basic explore function how
do I create a meeting that daily you
know there's one you like I would do a
youtube search on STL videos yeah yes so
we have quite a lot of opening videos on
her channel so that's obviously one good
way for people to reach out to us and
then Oliver secrets yeah that's how I've
been trying to learn the Sicilian barley
to stop this but it's not even one here
to stop stuff not sure if I'm actually
stopping stuff no getting crushed I'm
just I just get crushed all day but
people like it when they beat you then
they get to you know go around town and
like I beat Jonathan that's you know
that's what I live for making you guys
have to add a new follower see that's
what happens so we need you lose all
your games people follow you yeah
everyone's having fun not me but like
you guys are having fun I mean something
what do I even do oh my gosh just get
behind them it's almost dead behind the
pawns
I gotta do it this is getting tough Jack
just an endless series of checks what's
time pressure hiss surely he'll crumble
surely
for decent chicks so I'll play some bad
checks
all right what's happening stop crushing
me everybody sure what's the power of
two coordinated rooks that's what the
chats ain't yeah yeah I wish they were
coordinated then I could you can
probably do this here yeah but I don't
think it max we're gonna get check-in Oh
No yeah it's like people go I'm so close
I can beat you oh yes you didn't check
you easy victory I crushed this 1,400
yes No thank you for the super tough
game easy rose
yes well pretend your name is no super
super good game um yeah come in - myself
- one more oh one more all right we'll
take on the most respectable opponent we
can for the very last game with um
Combinator
oh no you you've changed this somehow
good luck thanks man yeah no Wow super
good games everyone's playing really
well today you changed this it was a
draw I'm assuming it was winning for
both sides and a draw at some point in
that last game so I should someplace
Mary goes here we go somebody requested
this for a while you blunder John yeah
blunder all the time but then I went
yeah did lose a game on this stream
though very upsetting so we'll see what
line combinator has against the Ragosa
normal approach
here case he wasn't ending up doing the
bishop here thanks for playing me yeah
thanks for the game very well played
so yeah this will have to do it for this
stream and then our next ring will be
tomorrow at 2 p.m. Central time 3 p.m. 3
p.m. Central time it'll be with club
manager Ryan Chester
it may be Dennis LaRue and maybe Dennis
the room I'm just saying that ok I mean
maybe maybe whoever's here yeah
a European it yeah yeah I guess I
they're already invited I believe so I
bow my do the easy jump tomorrow I'm
tired of getting crushed with like 1,400
so I'm gonna sit on that side and then
I'm gonna let Ryan get crushed by
fourteen hundreds that's the plants
easier to sit on this side it's way
easier I know it he does the snow so I
understand why Danny is in his position
it's a much better position maybe he's
gonna do this good just check one
squares checkmate oh yeah
[Music]
the checkmate other people have much
better understandings of these kinds of
positions so it's easy I mean yeah yeah
yeah cuz as this deep maneuver oh yeah
babies have been purposefully moving to
the natural squares yeah no no it's just
Bishop c7 Queen d6 somehow get rid of
the night and just pray that that works
yeah that's it if that doesn't work you
lost yeah I mean alright so you play
there's no way you gonna just we're just
doing this deep deep deep manoeuvre
there's really deep yeah the show just
gets a loop here though - is he go on so
it's like alright but here's the point I
know this thing might be weak betting on
how he takes back good point but now you
took back their way that's the price b6
well yeah I do
watch our protest League team later
today that'll be taken off you guys can
root for the st. Louis Archbishop's so
Bobby and Wesley are planned looking
forward to that one
I'm not sure who's gonna be playing here
at the club usually with two or three of
the players end up playing the club in
some play another location it's a fairly
strong team who's on our team so today
it's Bobby Wesley and then I think we
have fun stoking hot smoke Niemann and
rounding it off his Rosenthal who's like
the best board for of all time cuz he's
you know he's 2100 buddy
yeah like beats everybody right right so
that's pretty good huh he's strong
if you had a fairly strong team I'd say
yeah I think I think we're the favorite
I mean there's there's every team is
strong so it's not like one team will
just dominate and crush everybody are
you gonna suck your rippln after even no
pretension I'm not gonna sacrifice
anything yeah in a sack every game
that's people want to see blunder your
stuff tell me that it was a draw and
then it wasn't that is all of chess hey
don't take this how am I supposed to
defend it go back to the checkmate yes
I'm gonna draw lines and then go to
other places so confuse everybody
I mean it's time to wrap it up you got
to wrap it up noise yeah
she's shooting a story yeah yeah give me
a guestroom that's like three times
bigger than my actually yeah and even
sugars moving up in the world
yeah what's the twitch thing took off
Danny suddenly palace yeah party's right
scene Danny's previous location it was
not the largest Department in the state
Missouri I should have some good stuff
going how close are we defined you okay
so some just some deeply calculated I
use this dream where well I'm just the
guy in this side thank you oh this is
three - no how am I supposed to - yeah
no now I'm supposed to like win on the
board on the board is the chat just died
out or g7 what's is it is the chat just
over are you like not scrolling anymore
to see no squirrels yeah just stop
talking come on yeah
it's wrapping up
yeah okay chats wrapping it up to there
they're kind of over there's some threat
to take long yeah what makes it really
moves here first the worst thing that's
ever happened
Oh so I said Danny and I make a little
part
some people love you what's the problem
we are focusing on the game okay that's
the problem
three two you gotta focus on the game
[Laughter]
and you got a past one we're all gonna
die but all right thank you
the Combinator for you think you could
wind out of my sails at the ferry that
was a good combo yeah for the record
let's relive this tactic because this
could happen even to a really strong
player yeah no we don't play here here's
what you want to do is wait take that oh
maybe didn't didn't see this tactic no I
think there's a positional move though
cuz you're passed pawns not to be pushed
so now it's getting a little boy all
right let's get out of here yeah thank
you guys for watching